As another example, the attacker can
also hide part of the attack and
cause the IDS to miss
detecting the attack.
For example,
by sending fragments that overlap,
the IDS may discard a fragment that
overlaps with a previous fragment.
While the end host may accept both.
Again, the result is that,
the IDS will miss the attack.
Here's an illustration
of this evasion attack.
Again, the attackers sends
a packet although out of order,
both the end host and
the IDS will assemble them in order.
However, the two As here
are overlapping fragments.
The IDS drops the second A, so therefore
the IDS only sees A, T, T, C, K.
On the other hand, the end-host accepts
both fragments even though they overlap,
therefore the end-host sees A,
T, T, A, C, K.
In other words, the end-host gets
attacked by the traffic, yet
the IDS misses the attack.